[Música]
quien no ha sentido un bombardeo de
información en los últimos años
quien no ha sentido una sobresaturación
de noticias sobre todo de noticias
negativas
si no ha sentido que el mundo actual
está en caos
quien no ha sentido el ruido de los
medios y de la política muy ensordecedor
ruido muchísimo ruido y el ruido que
intentamos identificar con ideas
conceptos vemos en las noticias
corrupción cambio climático derechos
violentados de las mujeres
hoy en día infinidad de niños
atravesando desiertos enteros buscando
una mejor calidad de vida esto sin
mencionar a los 82 millones de
refugiados en el planeta es un caos y
con esta masa de personas sufriendo
existe la tendencia a categorizar las en
etiquetas
mujeres marginadas
comunidades lt negros pobres enfermos
migrantes
y existe la creencia que etiquetando a
seres humanos podemos dar cierto orden
en nuestras vidas no hay nada más
alejado de la realidad que es
más de una vez escuchado yo él es así
porque viene de este barrio
eso pasa siempre con la gente de color
los morochitos o a este le gustan los
hombres mira un migrante europeo y
previene un boliviano un venezolano no
se las etiquetas no se paran y la
historia si lo ha demostrado pero les
puedo asegurar que existen espacios
donde esas etiquetas no tienen la más
mínima importancia
les cuento algo muy especial en 2016
llega la argentina
como un desplazado más
perdido vacío y sin un propósito claro
había mucho ruido en mi cabeza
pero una mañana todo cambió escuché una
melodía
una melodía que silencio todo ese ruido
que había en mi mente y en mi corazón
era el sonido de un corno francés
me acerqué curiosamente y descubrí que
eran compañeros venezolanos
tocando
allí entendí que ese sonido cambió mi
vida y la de muchos otros
esos músicos son solo algunas de las
personas que escaparon de la mayor
crisis de la región que según auguró a
viernes plaza da casi 6 millones de
venezolanos
y obviamente este grupo ya tenía su
nueva etiqueta
desplazados exiliados migrantes
estos músicos del subterráneo provienen
del aclamado sistema de orquesta
conocido en todo el planeta
valiosísima labor estuvieron en los
mejores escenarios del mundo y ahora nos
toca verlos en el subte
qué pasó
y el brillo en sus ojos cargados de
mucha esperanza de mucha fortaleza
y es justamente allí donde surgió la
idea o la chispa inicial de agruparnos
en orquestas sinfónicas
no solo que sirviera como grupo de
contención sino como esas familias que
perdimos
les cuento la migración forzada es muy
agresiva
salen de un país por etiquetas y entrar
en otro donde se coloquen nuevas
etiquetas es terrible
antes éramos los músicos del sistema el
orgullo nacional ahora somos los músicos
del subte
definitivamente algo que había que hacer
e hicimos
al principio es una idea simple ingenua
latin box machine que raro sana no la
máquina de la voz latina o como decía
una amiga periodista la máquina de los
sueños y fue un sueño que comenzó con un
primer ensayo con 35 músicos muy
poderoso muy emotivo crecimos nos
adaptamos fuimos montamos maduramos hoy
en día somos 150 seres humanos 150 almas
de distintas nacionalidades no sólo
consolarnos uruguayos argentinos
chilenos colombianos la diversidad es de
ensueño y se respira
hoy en día tenemos el orgullo de generar
un espacio de encuentro con profundo
sentido de pertenencia un espacio donde
existe el reconocimiento donde existe la
co-creación y por sobre todo la
trascendencia a través de lo que sabemos
hacer que es arte
de pronto empezamos a sentir que algo
importante estábamos haciendo que algo
importante estaba pasando y semana a
semana se potenciaba la emoción de ese
encuentro
cada domingo se volvió algo sagrado
nosotros conseguimos en ese espacio una
convivencia perfecta donde había música
por doquier
y en ese espacio no había lugar para
tristezas solo compañía
sucede que cuando te sumerges en la
música orquestal
cuando nor que esté ejecuta una pizza de
mahler o merengue de juan luís guerra no
hay lugar para esas etiquetas absurdas
sencillamente es irrelevante de qué
nacionalidad o de qué color es cada
músico en qué barrio vives y rinko si es
pobre porque delante de una partitura no
existen esas etiquetas que nos separan
es lo poderoso de la música es lo
poderoso del arte delante de una
partitura existen son seres humanos
llenos de mucho talento de mucho
esfuerzo y muchísima disciplina
estos artistas tienen en su mente un
futuro lleno de esperanza eso es
maravilloso es lo lindo de este grupo
fíjense lo particular es maravilloso que
sucede dentro de una orquesta sinfónica
que cuando un integrante se equivoca
todos se equivocan
así que el trabajo en equipo es
indispensable en este tipo de espacios y
sobre todo la insistencia en cultivar la
alegría por el éxito del otro
y repito la insistencia en cultivar la
alegría por el éxito del otro es la
ética de la compasión es la ética de la
empatía es la ética de la inclusión tan
importante en estos ruidosos tiempos es
casi conductual y todo esto se
transfiere a tu vida familiar a tu vida
cívica a tu vida personal
no es posible llegar a las más excelsas
sinfonías de mendelssohn o de
tchaikovsky sin estos principios tan
básicos que sublime verdad
ahora imagínense que un ministerio
funciona como un ensamble
con esta estructura
pueden imaginarse un medio de
comunicación que apunte la pureza de la
ética en cada uno de sus mensajes
puede leer en titulares que se ha
llamado como pedro pérez y no el
venezolano o el colombiano atacó o robo
pueden imaginarse una asamblea o un
congreso de la nación donde se respeten
esas diferencias y se busquen lo que se
tiene que buscar que es la armonía de
los ciudadanos
para decir real verdad pero existe
porque existimos y queremos ser
escuchados es lo mágico de una orquesta
porque a través de sus prácticas hemos
logrado lo que difícilmente logra un
político un ministerio un medio de
comunicación y que es eso es la
inclusión en todos sus niveles
qué mágica sonar que esta verdad en
nuestra historia apenas comienza y no
sabemos no estamos seguros y vamos a
regresar o no eso también es irrelevante
porque luego de esta travesía tan
poderosa tan intensa nos sentimos tan
ciudadanos del mundo
que esto de las fronteras no tiene mayor
importancia
el ejemplo del activo que es sólo una de
las millones de iniciativas que están
esperando a ser descubiertas y a ser
apoyadas no sólo en la música también en
el teatro en la danza en el cine
sin duda yo les puedo asegurar que por
mi experiencia la experiencia de este
equipo tan poderoso es que la música en
la medicina del alma ha sido nuestra
medicina
y si nos detenemos y abrimos nuestros
oídos y nuestros corazones el sonido de
una orquesta puede ayudarnos a calmar
las enormes tensiones de la vida común
tan ruidos
y puede que sea inevitable que sigamos
utilizando etiquetas quizás no podamos
escapar de eso pero al menos vamos a
darle un uso positivo
qué tal etiquetas como emprendedor
luchador optimista trabajador soñador
así que la próxima vez que se sientan
abrumados con tu este ruido que genera
las etiquetas los medios el ruido de la
política de los conflictos no olviden
algo muy simple tomarse una pausa para
hacer silencio
porque solo en el silencio podemos
escuchar a la más hermosa melodía
qué es la voz de nosotros mismos
muchísimas gracias
ah